-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
We're hanging out
with Jerry Seinfeld!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is very exciting.
As of today,
180 episodes of "Seinfeld"
available on Netflix.
-Yeah, so that's 200 million
subscribers that they have.
This show has never been out
to that many people before.
It's really --
So, like, different countries,
different places
that have never seen it.
It's kind of cool.
-Yeah, it's bizarre.
-Yeah.
-I think it's fantastic.
-Yeah, yeah,
I'm very excited about it.
It's weird to me
that the show is like --
You did that "Sopranos" joke.
It's true that these shows
go away, and then
we breed a new audience...
-Yeah.
-...and then it's a new show.
-And this --
But now it's international
'cause Netflix
knows how to do it.
Yeah.
-Do they dub it?
So, Uruguay or wherever you are.
There it is.
Very exciting.
-You know, I also -- I --
When the show was on --
reran locally, I didn't watch
because I was such a superfan
that I was like --
Nancy, my wife,
watches you all the time.
-Right.
-And I go,
"I got to take a break.
Because...
-Why?
-Well, because I --
I start talking.
I start talking like you,
and I --
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
And I do that.
Yeah, and I talk like you,
and I do that, and I go --
I can't be --
I have to be me for once,
you know?
Yeah.
-And so I was me
for the last couple years.
And now I feel, with Netflix,
I'm gonna be you again.
-Now you can go back
to being me. Yeah.
-Yeah.
But 180 episodes is a lot of TV.
-Yeah, it's a lot.
We made nine years
worth of shows.
In those days,
you'd make 22, 24 a year.
-Right.
And great shows.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I don't even know
if there was a bad one.
Everything was --
-Everything varies in life.
-Yeah, yeah.
But I heard that you did
a "Seinfeld" promo on Netflix
where you were a Lego.
-Well, what happened is,
the Lego company came out
with a model of the set --
of the the apartment set
from the series.
-Yeah.
-And Netflix saying, "Hey, we
need to do a promo for your show
coming on the platform."
And I thought, "What if I
could get in that toy?
I want to get in there somehow."
-Yeah. Of course.
-"Can you get me in there?"
and they said,
"Yes, we're Netflix.
We can get you in there."
[ Laughter ]
So they did it.
They got me in there.
And here it is.
-Let's check it out.
-Coming this fall to Netflix,
"Seinfeld"!
It's must-see TV like you've
never seen it before.
Inspired by the wildly popular
Lego set model!
it's Lego Seinfeld!
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's blocky!
He's stompy!
He's one half
real organic matter.
He has C hands!
And he's every bit as funny
as his human counterpart.
-I am the human counterpart!
They shrunk me down.
-Quiet!
-I guess I'll have cereal.
-His milk never spoils.
♪♪
His pants clean in one wipe!
-I don't know what this is.
What are we selling here?
-Oh, sorry, Jerry.
You have no say.
We bought the series, and we
can do whatever we want with it.
And you.
-But I don't want to be a Lego!
[ Loud crunching ]
Pbht! Pbht!
I don't even know who I'm
working for at this point.
Hello?
This phone is not real.
-Lego Puddy sold separately.
-Yeah, that's right.
Lego Whatley not available.
Oh. What happened to Whatley?
He did like five episodes.
-Six!
-I don't know how this happened,
but I am not a toy.
-All 180 episodes
only on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
That is how you do it
right there.
That is -- That looked --
That looked great!
-It was fun.
-You were a Lego!
-Yes, I became a Lego.
-I love that.
I thought that was so --
Oh, it was perfect.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I -- I heard that you just went
on summer vacation.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No, I did not.
-Oh.
-I don't really like
going on vacations.
I don't like
that somebody else thinks
I'm gonna like something.
Just -- Just the idea --
You go to these places, "Here's
some things you'll love!"
You know,
the stand-up paddle board.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's like
a goldfish comes up and goes,
"Is that your top speed?"
and I go, "Yeah, I'm wide open.
This is it."
-You know, I can't --
I can't get that the Lego thing
out of my head, that scene.
-Yeah, it's kind of
a you bit, isn't it?
-I would love -- I feel like
I would love to be a Lego.
-Yeah, I know,
you probably would.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it really seems like
my kind of thing.
-It is kind of -- your kind of
thing, but I already did it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to be a Lego.
-You want to be Lego?
-Please?
-Okay, if you want, I can
take you into the Lego world
if you want to.
-We can do this?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
What do we have to do?
Come on over here.
-Okay.
All right.
What do we have to do?
-All right.
Now I want you to...
say -- you have to say,
"I don't want to be a Lego,"
but you have to say it
like I said it on the series.
Remember?
"I don't want to be a pirate."
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
-Which is --
That delivery is kind of like
a kid who's been told,
"This is
your Halloween costume."
-That's correct.
-And he doesn't like it.
-Okay.
"I don't want to be a Lego."
-You know,
you got to get up there.
You know, comedy,
you got to hit those notes.
-I -- I don't wanna be a --
-I don't want to be a Lego!
-Higher.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
Is that too high?
-That's too high.
And then it's --
it's got a down and then up.
-Okay.
-Want me to do it for you?
"I don't wanna be a Lego!"
[ Laughter ]
-"I don't want to be a Lego!"
-That's it.
Okay. You've got it.
All right. Hold my hand.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to be a Lego!
I don't want to be a Lego!
[ Ting! ]
Wow!
-Oh, my God!
-This is so neat.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It feels so good.
This is amazing being a Lego!
-This is great!
-Yes! Well, what do --
what do we do now?
-Well, let's continue the show.
-Yeah, okay.
All right. Have a seat, please.
-Oh, sure.
Don't you need your desk?
-I do need my desk.
-Okay. Well, let me help you
up on the desk.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you got --
[ Grunts ]
You have to...
[ Laughter ]
[ Both grunting ]
You got to roll over.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Anyway, you were saying?
-Uh, yeah,
I was just talking about, um...
You know, I don't really enjoy
going on vacations that much.
-Did you get a chance
to get away this summer?
-I did.
We went on a little trip,
and -- I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I just, uh...
You know,
the things they have there,
you know, like the zip line.
It's like, you know, let's risk
decapitation to find out
what it feels like
to be dry-cleaned.
[ Laughter ]
What's the point?
-What is the point?
-Yeah.
And I'm sure if we did
get seriously hurt
on this thing,
we'll do very well navigating
the court system
in this
fifth-world island nation
that's being run
by Komodo dragons.
[ Laughter ]
-That is so funny.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
[ Legos clattering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pbht!
-Jerry, could you have
ever imagined
that when "Seinfeld"
first premiered,
we'd have things like Netflix,
and you'd be able
to watch your show,
like, on your phone?
-No, I could never
imagine such a thing.
To me, the phone,
I kind of feel bad
sometimes for Google and Siri,
'cause they always have to be
so nice, you know?
"On it!"
"I'm sorry.
I didn't get that."
-Yeah.
You know, just once in a while,
I feel like they should go,
"Really? You don't know that?"
[ Laughter ]
"No, no. You rest. I'll get it.
I'll figure it out."
[ Laughter ]
Just once
I want to hear Siri go.
"Why don't you learn
how to enunciate,
and maybe
we don't have to do this?"
-That's exactly correct.
-"Not always my fault,
you know."
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Legos clattering ]
[ Laughter ]
Enough water --
Enough water for me.
[ Laughter ]
This -- This has been fun,
but I have other guests
I have to interview.
-Oh.
-So I think we should get back.
How do we -- How do we get?
-You want to get back?
-Yeah.
How do we do it?
-Um...
I know how.
Let's stand up.
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ohh! Pfft!
What was that?
-That was a part of your cup.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Get that out of -- thank you.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
The worst thing is...
-Come on down.
...when you step on
a Lego barefoot.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pfft!
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
I had no idea you used a piece.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
So, how do we get back?
-Uh, hold my hand.
[ Laughter ]
Now just say,
"There's no place like 6B."
-There's no place like 6B.
There's no place like 6B.
[ Ting! ]
-And that's why your spouse
is like a rescue pet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jimmy?
Jimmy, are you listening to me?
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Just never mind.
But thanks to Jerry Seinfeld,
everybody.
All episodes of "Seinfeld"
are available on Netflix now!